Es ist der perfekte abend für ein romantisches date im freien einen heiratsantrag oder eine super mysteriöse grillparty mit freunden
die dann in einer full red moon party
endet denn zunächst wird der gigantische sommer vollmond auf gehen bevor er sich dann blutrot färbt und das ist nicht nur eine gewöhnliche
totale mondfinsternis sondern sogar die längste des ganzen jahrhunderts was genau
passiert und wann und wo ihr das himmelsspektakel am besten verfolgen könnt das alles jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Genauer gesagt heute abend wird es der fall sein der vollmond wird aufgehen wenn die sonne noch gar nicht richtig
untergegangen ist kurz vor 21 uhr aber wundert euch nicht so richtig nach vollmond sieht er nicht aus
denn ungefähr die hälfte der mond scheibe ist schon vom schatten der erde bedeckt und so wird eine eher
ungewöhnliche mondsichel am himmel zu sehen sein die schrumpft dann in den nächsten 30 minuten ziemlich zusammen gewalt
nordwestlicher man sich befindet desto länger dauert es bis der mond am himmel erscheint insgesamt wird sich das himmelsspektakel
eine ungewöhnlich lange zeit hinziehen expertinnen und experten
rechnen mit einer totalen mondfinsternis von 21 30 bis 23 uhr 15 und
kurz vor 11 uhr 30 ist die mondscheibe das schon fast komplett vom erdschatten bedeckt ab jetzt ist der typisch
blutrote und riesengroße mond zu bewundern in diesem zustand wird der mond auch als blutmond
bezeichnet der grund die erde schiebt sich zwischen
mond und sondern wirft ihren schatten auf den mond bis sie ihn ganz verdeckt die erde kommt also die
sonnenstrahlen ab doch einige werden von der erdatmosphäre gebrochen und zum mond geworfen das sind langweilige lichtstrahlen und auch
infrarotstrahlen und die liegen halt im roten bereich und die geben dem mond diese
geheimnisvolle gestalt des blutmond ist etwas korrekter als die bezeichnung
mondfinsternis wäre hier also so etwas wie
mond rötung der begriff blutmond deutet es ja schon an übrigens ist der mond dann gar nicht so groß wie es scheint tatsächlich
handelt es sich um den kleinsten vollmond des jahres denn er hat auf seiner bahn um die erde gerade den größten
abstand zu uns und das ist auch die erklärung für die lange dauer der mond dann ist doch die horizont nähe sorgt für eine
optische täuschung
bezüglich seiner größe im direkten vergleich zur landschaft oder gebäuden sieht er eben deutlich
größer aus damit er die mondfinsternis auch wirklich in vollen zügen genießen können
sucht euch einen erhöhten standort mit blick nach osten bis süden wichtig ist die freie sicht zum horizont
denn die mondscheibe wandert von ost südost in den süden und steigt etwa zwei
handbreit über den horizont doch sogar ein haus oder ein wald im blickfeld könnten euch dann die sicht verhageln denn zum höhepunkt der
mondfinsternis
befindet sich der rote blutmond nur eine handbreit hoch
achtet außerdem darauf dass ich möglichst wenig licht wählen um euch herum befinden denn in der zunehmenden dämmerung während der mondfinsternis sind
sternenhimmel und sogar die
milchstraße dann besonders gut zu erkennen die in berlin ist das nicht so leicht aber auf dem land da sind dann sogar
gestirne zu erkennen die sonst vom mond überstrahlt werden zu sehen sind über dem mond übrigens das sternbild adler
und um ihn herum die sternbilder wassermann und
steinbock schien heller als alle anderen sterne ringsherum wird aber der mars sein den er schon in der frühen dämmerung
beobachten können er steht genau in opposition zur sonne also ihr gegenüber auf der milchstraße werdet ihr auch den saturn
schimmern sehen also im hintergrund die milchstraße davor der saturn und ab 23 15 bis etwa
130 wird sich die mondscheibe langsam wieder aus dem kernschatten der erde
herausschieben ab etwa 1 uhr 30 nachts steht sie dann wieder als vollmond scheibe am himmel das alles mal vorausgesetzt
es ist gutes wetter und der himmel ist unbedeckt dann ist das himmelsspektakel nicht nur in deutschland und im restlichen europa sondern auch in südamerika
in afrika in asien und australien zu sehen und wer übrigens noch mal eine solche konstellation
sehen möchte der muss
105.000 jahre warten also bisher saturn maß und so weiter alles
dann auch sehen wir vielleicht dann doch besser heute abend anschauen und wenn ihr in zukunft kein video von mir verpassen wollte übrigens täglich
dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann um gibt er die ein wenig
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jenem upload und zwar noch vor allen an
täglich um garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür je klingen aber nicht die
genau geht locker vergessen und hier geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken mit mondstation
eishöhlen auf dem mond entdeckt bis dann
bleib dran